this meeting between taiwan's President
XI Nguyen and U.S officials in Taipei
has high political implications
the government says and needs
international support as threats from
China get louder and closer
I would like to reiterate that the
people of Taiwan love democracy seek
peace and are Keen to fulfill their
responsibility in the International
Community
China considers Taiwan as part of its
territory and has not ruled out using
Force to take it the U.S says it's ready
to expedite weapon sales
as a house Foreign Affairs committee
chairman I sign off on all four military
sales
including weapons in Taiwan
and I promise you madam President we
will deliver those weapons
now China has launched three days of
military exercises around Taiwan a
response to the Taiwanese president
meeting earlier this week with U.S House
speaker Kevin McCarthy
taiwan's fighter jets responded with
their own drills as fears grow about a
possible escalation it will be
interesting to see just exactly how far
the Chinese are prepared to push this if
they do stop and inspect ships in the
Taiwan Strait and the Taiwanese say no
we're not going to comply then there's
the potential then for that to escalate
into some sort of exchange of fire but
China remains defiant
the Taiwan issue is not about democracy
it's an issue concerning China's
sovereignty and territorial Integrity
Taiwan is an inalienable part of our
country
Taiwan understands it needs
International backing especially from
the United States the question is
whether it will be enough to deter
Beijing
Al Jazeera